[Music]
[Applause]
paulie i just saw that you put down rick
eisen
for instead of rich eisen on the rundown
yes you have rick isaac rick
come on
you're better than that well that's kind
of a cool rick eisen sounds like a
private detective rick isaac no he'd be
dick eisen no yeah no you're a private
detective i'm rick ice rick eisen
groundbreaking let me just get to rich
anybody call you rick before rich
great intro guys
[Laughter]
really appreciate it coming before i
come on talk more about how lewis
riddick broke stuff down paul great job
man
you watching yeah but you know i was
watching because i was texting you
yes that's correct i appreciate it yes i
was i was watching yeah
so paul you're watching louis riddick on
the mother ship and he put down rickeis
i have multiple tvs dan i was watching
charles davis watching everybody
paul do we need to sidebar i mean
what's going on we have what about once
a year
uh how you feeling today i'm good yeah
i'm good yeah last night was uh it was a
blast um it was uh wild i i
i still can't believe we're in vegas
because this place as you know in the
nfl have not really been intertwined
that much
uh on the forefront
i'm sure a lot of folks in this town
have been very
uh football centric nfl centric but i
can't believe we're here dan it's kind
of wild but i can't remember a draft
either though rich where
you know three minutes before the
commissioner gets up there we don't know
who you had ian rappaport on he goes i i
don't
i think it's trayvon walker but i don't
know
why do you think there was this mystery
with the well the jaguars were really
tight-lipped about it and there was no
quarterback that just screams down at
you and there was also no defensive
player uh you know outside of aiden
hutchinson that kind of screamed at you
and
you know travon walker as you saw was
part of a team that
that had four other players taken from
him two packers took
two uh georgia defenders and
so i i mean it was kind of way up in the
air and then right around pick uh
11 as soon as the jets took garrett
wilson
that's when the first trade came in
um and then a record nine trades in the
first round including two involving
actual players in the nfl that's never
happened before either
how much of a heads up do you get
on a trade maybe not the draft pick but
the trade
the trade
there's no there's no heads up that a
trade is coming i mean we we realize
that at the same time everyone else is
when they switch out on the board the
team that's on the clock i have no idea
they could tell me which pick has been
chosen but we specifically asked not to
not to know i'm not on twitter i put my
phone down
um except to read texts from you and
others who are sending it to me but i
stay off of twitter i don't want to know
we just want to have a reaction i know
that that might come across as
we're making it up because folks at home
are on their second window and no
information that we don't
but that's the nature of the draft now
can i talk to rich the jets fan
yes hold on a minute okay he's going to
go get rich and there he is hey rich hey
how did you what did you think of the
jets draft that was unbelievable uh
honestly there's there's not a very high
bar to to to leap over when you're a jet
fan on a draft night um but uh i loved
sauce gardener i wanted that pick i've
been literally saying it on my show
every day uh he's exactly what the jets
need certainly when you've got
um tyree kill now in the division uh the
bills looking the way they looked
against the chiefs um the the dolphins
now still loaded at the spot they say to
bill belichick why don't you have
devante parker so they need to have
someone who not only can cover them but
wants to
and and then uh to add garrett wilson at
receiver those are the two best players
at their positions that daniel jeremiah
had on his board
and then to come back in and and uh and
go get jermaine johnson the second who
who was top 10 on daniel's board as well
to get him
later on in the first round and still
have a second round choice tonight
that's 38th overall from the sam darnold
trade
um
i i think it's
it's a coup it's exactly what um the
jets needed at those positions and it
was smart they they worked the board i
can't believe i'm saying that about a
jets draft unreal
what do you think of what the eagles did
i like that too i i saw you left them
out of your poll question
today um because they they could they
could they could have
uh claimed to having had the best draft
last night as well you know i saw you
had the giants and the ravens there you
know the giants did well um with
thibodeaux and neil i liked the ravens
uh going with kyle hamilton a moment
after they seemingly lost
out on jordan davis the eagles who
traded up right in front of them
um and then they came back in at the end
of the first round as well for another
player uh i i think the eagles coming
away with jordan davis and then drafting
aj brown and and
and getting him to a contract that
appears to be right around 20 million 21
million dollars a year which is
um i think uh a market a fair market
value
um you know
uh um
signing for for for the eagles
um man i thought they did a really good
job last night too
yeah you know when you throw in the
trades and they're actual players being
traded and these are starters and then
you know jalen hurts is now on the clock
like we got your toys here uh you wonder
what's going to happen with ryan
tannehill you know with tennessee as
they move forward uh you had lamar
jackson with the wtf when hollywood
brown like there was there was a lot
more intrigue and i said this the last
couple of days going into the draft it
doesn't seem like there's drama but
there will be drama
it just happens you know the they may
not be recognizable names it may not be
big names with quarterbacks there but
they're still interesting moves you know
the steelers what they did the patriots
what they did the cowboys drafting an
offensive lineman you're going what are
they doing um and then you get the
trades there
uh jacksonville's always interesting
detroit i like what detroit did
but if you were saying
this this is the most puzzling move of
round one
it would have to be belichick choosing a
kid out of chattanooga
um corey strange who everyone loves and
you know but it's one of those pics
where anybody else makes it they're
you're killing them this is the typical
in bill we trust pick
uh i enjoyed on on our coverage
showing the
uh
section of mystified patriots fans who
are in the draft hall i mean just
imagine you fly all the way out from
logan you know to vegas to hang out in
vegas all night long watch bill trade
down and they'd take some guy from
chattanooga you have to google
you know
well what did you think of the rams
reaction when les speed and sean mcvay
are
talking to the media and they're having
a draft party and all of a sudden they
go what
cole strange from chattanooga to the
patriots and then in the case like we
wasted our time looking at him thinking
he'd be there at 104
you know in the draft and he's gone uh
at 29. yeah that that's the one right
there but
you know who who knows man you know
obviously the packers need to get a
receiver for for aaron rodgers they went
and got two
defenders off of one of the best
defenses we've seen in college football
and we'll see what happens tonight
aj brown second round pick debo second
round pick dk second round pick
obviously you can get
game changing receivers in the first
round tonight rich eisen nfl network
emmy nominated host and you can see them
throughout the coverage tonight they
start at seven easter and also saturday
noon easter and also 18th annual run
rich run errors during the coverage of
rounds four through seven wait that's
not how long it takes you to run it
round
nicely done dan nicely done um yeah you
can time me you can't time me through
picks four through seven i know
uh you know hourglass but yeah we we uh
we ran it in the rose bowl this year i
like how i'm so competitive when rich
first ran i remember texting him i think
i said i could run faster than that and
risk goes that's not what this is about
like i i'm i'm competing with rich and
he's raising money and i'm thinking what
am i doing like it was one of those
return of serves and i went ow okay i
got it
yeah just uh it's it's it's but i've
been used to that dan just you know you
being oddly competitive at the most
inappropriate moments and that's why uh
you're beloved
and you're the only one you know only
one speed as well um so yes nfl.com run
rich run to raise money for for saint
jude we're going to be doing that um all
throughout the week and and beyond um
biggest well what do you think second
round if you were going to go here is
your storyline for second round tonight
uh running backs we haven't seen them uh
no no tight ends but running backs and
then the quarterbacks i think tonight's
the night baker gets traded
if um if somebody goes through the the
evening towards the the end of the
second round don't get the quarterback
they want if desmond ritter and malik
willis go off the board and a team that
wanted him didn't get him
um and and then then they might go for
baker mayfield obviously carolina
doesn't have a pick all the way to
tomorrow
so
it you know really it's the browns are
on the clock do they really want to come
through this draft with him there
on the team do they really want to take
him into
more otas and the mandatory otas they
really want to sit there in the summer
thinking that they have him in their
back pocket in case there's an injury or
something like there were a suspension
for for desean watson like what's the
point of holding on to him and and if
you're paying desean watson that much
guaranteed money
what's the big deal about eating more of
it obviously it's their money
but
um i i don't understand why you would
even hold on to baker mayfield this long
he's an asset of course but he's no
longer your asset
and and so uh i think tonight would be
the night you know josh rosen was traded
on night two
uh for a second round pick i i just
don't know if that's what you'll get
back for baker if you're still standing
pat on not eating his salary that's kind
of what's at play tonight yeah i i would
take baker mayfield if i'm seattle and i
can get a guy who has proven to be a
good quarterback
and he's going to be 18 million dollars
and maybe the browns pick up a good
portion of that and i have him on a
one-year deal and i just say baker come
on in and prove yourself
chip on your shoulder
i mean i'd rather do that than
you know take one of these these
quarterbacks i know seahawk fans might
not like to hear this um but it's the
truth they signed geno smith and they
signed gino smith and they liked geno
smith they really really do they liked
what they saw out of him when russell
got hurt last year they have drew lock
they might go ahead and draft a
quarterback tonight and thus i think the
the seattle shop would be closed for
baker
it seems like carolina might be the the
best spot for him i don't know if the
saints are going to go in that direction
either
um
the the the the windows of opportunity
are really dwindling here for baker
mayfield
and um i don't know why the browns would
want to be left holding on to him
when they hit the summer i mean
it just i don't know what way out there
would be other than cutting him which i
know they definitely don't want to do
that so maybe trading him tonight would
be the smartest move congrats on the
emmy nominations there
and
and uh we'll be watching rounds four
through seven on saturday you can see uh
rich in the run rich run and that'll be
on the nfl network so i don't
when you said we'll be watching is that
can i count on that that the entire
dan patrick no no no no no okay my wife
and i
maybe
it could be my me and my puppy
okay but we'll be watching
understood the royal we yeah we'll be
watching very good i appreciate that
thanks guys thanks that's rick eisen i
guess
[Laughter]
take care what a jerk i am thank you
rich that's uh rich eisen
paul you put down rick eisen and i've
never done that before no you haven't i
kind of like it though i don't think he
did